All right. I hope everybody's doing
good.
>> Yeah. You you still a Muslim?
>> All right. So, until I die?
>> Yeah. I hope not.
>> Hope it for yourself. Convinced with my
heart, with my mind that I'm on the de
of truth. I have a couple not a couple
questions, but a question. It's a very
is a very direct question and it's with
good intentions to be honest.
>> Well, we have a question. A really good
question.
>> Exactly.
>> Yeah. It's it's in the same topic
because I'll tell you because I've been
following your stream for a couple
minutes and when he um when you stated
the when you stated an ayah from the
Quran and he said between brackets you
told him we don't care about what's
between brackets. It doesn't say
explicitly. Am I wrong? I'm quoting
you're right.
>> Yeah. I don't care about what
translators or commentators add in the
brackets what's not part of the verse.
>> All right. No problem. So here comes my
question and this is very genuine. It's
not disrespectful at all. Why do you
think do you have the authority or you
have the the ability to judge a book
where you don't know the language? You
didn't study like for example going to
for example you're going to
>> I can answer this for you. You can
trying to debate a doctor about his I
don't know he studied 14 years of
medicine and then you all right please
I'll I'll hear
>> yeah so so the reason why I believe that
I can make judgments or can come to
logical conclusions about what the Quran
is saying is because I just read the
Quran. I read what it says and I take
what it says cuz I love the Quran. I
love the original Quran before it got
corrupted. So, um, when people come to
me and they and they show that they hate
the Quran by twisting it or adding to
it, I don't I'm not going to let them
off. I'm not going to let them get away
with that, you know.
>> Okay. So, so could you give me please an
example of people like people adding to
the Quran or something like this that I
could look
>> You just you just give one.
>> Go.
>> You lit. You literally just gave what
you're asking Avery to show. Where in
the verse does it say Quran?
>> What? I was quoting him. Doesn't mean
that I added the word.
>> You You agreed
>> with the other guy.
>> Yeah. You agreed that the other guy
added the word Quran into the verse,
right?
>> That's not my That's not my topic. I was
>> That was It's the example you I mean,
and maybe I'm confused.
>> All right, I'll tell you why. I'll tell
you why.
>> Just really quick, I want to I want to
consult with my imam real quick.
>> Imm he brought this up, right? He
brought what the other guy was talking
about though, right?
>> That that's he literally instead of uh
starting a new con conversation with us,
he really brought what was the other guy
was talking back up
>> and then asked you to show them where
and we just Yeah, I'm with you on that
one. Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> That's the simple That's a simple
definition of quoting. If you quote
somebody, it doesn't mean you you
confirm what he's saying. I was quoting
him. So the guy the guy that you were
quoting I'm asking you the guy that you
were quoting
>> added the word Quran to the verse
correct
>> he didn't add the word Quran he told you
that he saw between brackets
>> which is an addition which is an
addition to the what the Quran is saying
right cuz when it's in brackets it's not
can we be clear that if it's in brackets
it's not part of the verse
>> it is of course it's not of course it's
not
>> so it's an addition to the verse right
>> so you're saying every every note that
there is And the Bible is an addition to
the Bible. It's an explanation.
>> We're not talking about the Not talking
about the Bible. We're talking about
>> in general. In general, not in All
right. This is a very trivial topic. I
think if you It's very trivial talking
about
>> So, just be clear, you do agree that
that is an addition to the Quran, right?
Cuz it's not part of the original Quran.
>> It's not an addition. It's an
explanation. Of course, it's not in the
Quran.
>> But why is it?
>> Because you're trying to implicate like
that there is an addition and trying to
make a false point. Okay. It's like
>> if you can't be honest with this, then
this is going to be a tough a tough time
and a quick conversation.
>> I've been I've been I've been
>> a word in parentheses is not a part of
the actual verse. Right.
>> Of course not.
>> Of course not. That's right. It's not
even
>> So if they put a word in parenthesis and
add it to the verse, then they've just
added to the verse. Correct.
>> They add it to the translation of the of
of the text. Yes, I agree.
>> Right. Because in Arabic it doesn't even
it doesn't even have this kind of
>> Exactly. So they're adding to the Quran
which therefore I'm not okay with cuz I
love the Quran. I love the original. So
when they add to it I it it it it does
something to me, man. It it it it it
like tears my heart apart. I can't stand
it.
>> Fair enough. Fair enough. It's the same
feeling when you add to the Bible from
our side. But it's people when people
add to the Bible, I get the same feel. I
love the Bible more than I love the
Quran. So, if somebody's adding to the
Bible,
>> you're like, "This is this is this is
the reason why I I dislike Jehovah's
Witnesses
more more than I would dislike a
dishonest Muslim because the Jehovah's
Witnesses is is claiming to use the
Bible and they're adding to the Bible."
So, they're they're worse than Muslims,
you know. So, yeah.
>> So, why do you hate your brothers?
>> All right. So, I'll tell that's the
point. I'm I'm [clears throat] not going
to get with you. I don't know. We'll see
how where the conversation goes. But the
point I want to make now is I'm reading
I'm reading the the verse in Arabic. It
says
so he's saying the book he has revealed
to his messenger. Let's say we disagree.
All right. All right. Avery,
we disagree. I say Muhammad, you say no,
it doesn't say Quran because we say it's
the Quran. You say no, it's not the
Quran and all of that. If we are in in a
in disagreement, who do you think we we
make a judge? Let me ask the imam.
>> That's a good question. Imam Claus, if
if we're in a disagreement with the
Muslim about what the Quran is saying,
what should be the judge between us,
what the Quran is actually saying? What
would give us that
>> even? Yes,
>> I think that it would be the previous
scripture or the Quran
>> and not somebody not somebody who spoke
Arabic and who lived in that area and
who transmitted the Quran verbally
verbally and who still who's still
living the traditions of the prophet at
that time and who can give us the
context and
>> are you on
>> are you on team Allah or are you on team
Dawa?
>> Does the sun have three legs? What?
>> That's the same question for me.
>> That's the same question. It has no
sense. It's a meaningless question.
>> So team Allah is that they they accept
the Quran for Allah giving it the way it
is.
>> Team Dawa wants to explain what Allah
meant when he said these verses.
>> You see the difference?
>> No, that's very that's your own that's
your own uh that's your own definition.
I think that the team da doing a very
good job of
>> so you are team da
>> it's not it's not about being team
>> I'm a Muslim I'm a Muslim
you can go on and ask your question
because right
>> well why do you hate the Quran then
>> it's preparing your PS
>> does the sun have three legs it's the
same it's the
>> or just say I don't hate the Quran
whichever right
>> you can ask do you hate the Quran and I
would say no instead of why do they go
so you don't You're saying that you
don't hate the Quran. So you love you
cherish the Quran, don't you?
>> What do you mean by TV, bro?
>> I love it. I read it.
>> You love it. You read it. You cherish
it. Correct.
>> Please. To the point.
>> I'm I'm not sure why you can't say that
you cherish your Quran. I cherish my
Bible.
>> Cherish my Bible.
>> I just don't
don't waste everybody's time. And to the
point, which verse do you want to check?
So if a law says something, should we
accept what Allah says or should we go
and find out from somebody else what
Allah says?
>> All right. Very good question. It's a
very good question.
>> There you go.
>> Can I get an answer to it?
>> Well, you don't you don't you don't
understand Arabic. I don't know.
>> I would love you don't need to
understand Arabic to get answer to that
question. And and I think that's the
that's the very essence of the problem
because you can you can bring bring up
right now a Muslim another Muslim and
I'll tell him an Arabic word and he
would have no clue what does that mean.
So by that I mean there are some words
that you cannot understand from the
Quran. So you go to the you go ask the
scholarships you go ask the imams about
this.
>> That's all in Arabic. Yeah. What? It's
all in Arabic. And what about what? Now
this is this is one thing that I wanted
to point out. Do you believe that your
Quran is a clear book? It is a detailed
explanation of all things
>> for the basics of my religion. It is
definitely how
>> now see this is this you're going to
start throwing a lot under the bus. Does
it say that your Quran is a detailed
explanation of all things or what you
say? It [laughter] is the ayah the ayah
because I can bring you another ayah
that says that there is
>> are you are you okay are you all blink
twice
>> I hope you are I hope you are as well
>> I hope you are as well
>> in trouble man because it seems like
you're off right now did you every time
all right did you finish
>> did you hear the question that I asked
you
>> so that's what you guys do every time
you you can try not to be personally
attacking the other present. It's going
to be very helpful in your life as well.
>> You know the question that I asked you,
sir.
>> Could you repeat, sir?
>> Thank you. See how easy that is. When
you don't listen, it's hard to keep uh
the question on your mind. So, in your
Quran, it says that your Quran is a
fully detailed explanation of all things
or or
does your Quran say it's a detailed
explanation of things that you need to
know?
>> All right. Could you give me the verse?
>> Chapter 12 [snorts] verse 111.
>> Chapter 12 verse, please. Avery
>> 111.
>> 100. Appreciate it.
>> Now, see, I'll I'll grant you that Allah
is not saying if you read the Quran,
you're going to know how to make a
peanut butter and jam sandwich. It's not
a detailed explanation that you're going
to go out and you're going to be able to
change your tire and stuff like that.
But what I would say is that when your
Quran says that it's a detailed
explanation of all things, it's all
things explained in the Quran.
That'd be fair, wouldn't it?
>> Fair.
>> All right. So, so you were saying that
it's a detailed explanation of all
things. So, that's means that it should
have every aspect of our life explained
in detail. It should explain it should
explain all the concepts that it is
talking about in the Quran. Would you
agree?
>> Definitely. All right.
>> Excellent. Now, do you know that there
is another verse that says that there
are clear verses and unclear verses?
>> That's not a contradiction.
>> I didn't say it was. I just asked you if
you knew that verse was in your Quran.
>> Yeah, I do because I I I see where
you're going. So is that is that verse
in your Quran?
>> It is.
>> So how can your Quran be fully detailed
and explained and explained but there be
un or there be ambiguous verses in there
that aren't explained?
>> All right. So for example another there
is a very very simple example. We're
going to bring another Arab and you will
tell him to explain the three first
letters of the surah.
So he's
just I'll let you I'll let you pick.
>> Yeah. Go ahead. You had a long pause
there. Done.
>> Yeah. I was confused by that pause mama.
You paused for a minute. So
>> thank you very much.
>> So when you ask him about the meaning,
he's not going. Nobody knows the meaning
except from Allah. That's very a
consensus amongst all the scholarships.
the scholar scholarship. So the the the
good question is to understand the
meaning of this three letters or to miss
the understanding of it. Does it does it
change my religion? Does it like reduces
my understanding of the religion? Does
it my my uh let's say my afterlife lies
upon lies upon religion? No. Lies upon
understanding those three letters.
Absolutely not. All the aspects of my
life, how to pray, how to make to for
pilgrimage, for everything else is
explained, how to get
>> sal like the Holy Spirit, like details
on the Holy Spirit. You'd be able to
know because the Quran explains it,
right?
>> So, another topic. You want to jump to
another topic? All right.
>> No. Well, you went to these three
letters, right? That's not something
that anybody brought up. But you're
saying that these three letters are the
ambiguous verses that you're talking
about in the Quran and only Allah knows
these three letters and nobody else. So
I'm wondering is this the same when it
comes to the Holy Spirit?
>> I would appreciate if you go straight to
the ayah because I would prefer to go
straight to the ayah with you.
>> Okay. So as the holy spirit
>> is it the same as the holy spirit? What?
What's
>> Yeah, those three letters.
>> In which sense that like the when the
Quran is talking about the Holy Spirit,
it's not
>> Do you have the details about the Holy
Spirit? Is there an explanation of the
Holy Spirit?
>> Let's find out. Do you have a verse?
Let's check it together. We can check
>> I'm not I don't memorize the whole
Quran.
>> So, what is Sah Isra is that surah 17?
>> Yeah.
>> Surah 17 I 85. Correct logic.
>> Let me check. I think so. I believe
there it says then ask you oh prophet
about the spirit say its nature is only
known to my lord.
>> Yeah.
>> So what about those details about the
Holy Spirit? Again the Quran talks about
the Holy Spirit. The Quran says that
it's a fully detailed explanation of all
things. But here it says the knowledge
of the Holy Spirit is only with the law.
How do you square that circle?
>> It's the same is the same answer. as my
salvation or my life lies upon
understanding what the the Holy Spirit
is.
>> So you're saying that you do not
>> So is your Quran unclear when it comes
to the Holy Spirit?
>> It's not unclear because we have there
there are it's not. It's not unclear
because that's not
>> Wait a minute.
>> You're like is this going to take me to
heaven or to the hellfire? What do I
need to know about this for? because
you're basically throwing that under the
bus as if it was the ambiguous verses.
>> I'm not I'm not I'm not throwing it
under the bus. It's just you being
silly. So, you just can take this
gestures from your character and you be
an awesome an awesome speaker and be
respectful. We're just having you don't
have to make all this gesture. But
anyways, I I wanted to say that it is
not the only verse that speaks about the
Holy Spirit. There are other verses that
speaks that speak about the Holy Spirit.
their knowledge. Where is the knowledge
of the Holy Spirit?
>> Is it in the Quran or is it only with
Allah?
>> And what do you mean by the knowledge of
the about the the Holy Spirit?
>> 17 ayah 85. Just go ahead and read it
and then you tell us where the knowledge
of the spirit is. Is it in the Quran or
is it with Allah?
Let me get it in English because I can't
translate it myself. So, it's 1785.
>> I thought I did pretty good off the
dome. I'm just saying
>> that was pretty good, Chris. Did great.
>> I I didn't even remember the verse. And
I'm the shake.
>> You had the chapter, though. You did
have the chapter.
>> Mhm.
>> 17. So, so
>> have the battle.
>> Has have the battle. Remember
when you're done reading this verse, the
question that you need to answer is, is
the knowledge with Allah or is it in the
Quran?
>> That's that's a very ambiguous question
you're asking. [laughter]
>> Allah is all you trying to say? What are
we doing here, man?
>> What we doing? What are we doing here,
man? Golly gosh.
>> Wow.
>> They hate that Quran, man. I hate the
Hey, congratulations.
You hate your Quran, bro.
>> All right. All right. I just want one
and I can I can go afterwards. Could you
please and for just make a correlation
between what what I said and by people
be hating the Quran was
>> did you hear what you said?
>> I heard myself. Could you tell me what's
what's the what's the leazison between
the the two of of them?
>> Yeah. So you don't you hate the Quran
because you don't accept the Quran the
way it is. What you try to do is you try
to tell us what the Quran wants to say
and accept the Quran for what it is. If
you truly loved and you truly cherish
the Quran, you would take and accept it
for what it is. And it seems like you're
not.
>> We're going to
just closure if you don't mind. I think
that's that's exact I think that's
generally speaking. No offense, no
disrespect. I think you got you pe the
Christians and I think the Jews.
>> What you mean YOU
[laughter]
>> why do they put a
>> that you know more than the So you think
you more you know more than the scholars
you know more and you're trying to
explain the Quran and say this and say
that you you sound like you went full
Muslim brother full
>> I don't I don't think you understand
your lingo
>> and I don't like your tone or your
vernacular. What you mean you people?
You people. You people. [laughter]
>> I think I think that's that's very very
respectful when it comes to what you you
be saying to the others.
>> Be referring to us as you people is
respectable.
>> So you're not people.
>> I I hope you're not animals. You're
people. You're human.
>> Oh. So now we animal.
>> All right. Man, you going too far now,
man. Now you're pushing the book.
>> What you mean? What you mean animal,
bro? So, could you just wind back what I
said? I hope you're not animals and
you're human.
>> Why would you Why would you hold that?
>> Because you got offended by calling you
people.
>> You got animals.
>> I think I think we're going out. I think
we going
>> animals.
>> I want to know what's wrong with
animals. What's wrong with animals?
>> Animals don't have minds. So, they don't
they don't
>> Did you know that the monkeys had enough
sense to stone another monkey for
adultery?
done talked to Solomon lo then then why
they're not going to be held to held to
questions in the here
>> after the monkey was stoned for adultery
>> adultery
>> they're held accountable for their sins
>> no
they were Sharia compliant this is Islam
bro this is in your hadith
>> it's Islam
>> are you familiar with me with monkey
being stoned for adultery cuz she
committed Oh, yeah. She cheated on she
cheated on her husband and uh and
[snorts] then it was a counsel. They
stole this monkey, bro. And then and
then somebody else joined in and helped
them stone the monkey.
>> A human came along and was like, "Hey,
they stoning that monkey." What he
stoning them for? Oh, let me give me a
rock.
>> Yeah. It was it was it was too man.
>> When you read the whole story, hey, that
that the the husband monkey, he was in
his right at that point in time because
the female monkey smelt like the other
monkey. No, like right afterward, she
jumped right beside him again. She
didn't even go have a shower word.
That's
>> right. So why is the geckos Why are the
geckos being punished for not helping
out Abraham in a fire?
>> Yeah.
>> Right. So So you're implying this if
they get punished if they get punished
now they're going to be punished in the
afterlife as well.
>> Look, look at this. Look at this. This
is Sah Bkari 3849. Let me show you
brother
S. Bkari 3849. It's on the screen.
narrated narrated am bin ma mahm during
the pre-Islamic period of ignorance I
saw a she
>> stop now you can just
period of ignorance so you can just stop
>> let me read the hadith
>> yeah go on if you want I mean that's
enough for me
>> let me read the all right I saw a she
surrounded by a number of monkeys. They
were all stoning it because it had
committed illegal sexual intercourse. I
too stoned it along with them.
>> Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow.
>> I got one question before we get into
this logic. How did the monkeys know
that stoning was a punishment for
infidelity? And who was the Moses monkey
that gave them that law?
>> Well, first of all,
When Allah reveals a re, you guys don't
understand, when Allah sends a
revelation down, it's for the alamine,
all of creation, for everyone. Okay? So
when you don't know, that's your problem
by talking about what you don't know.
>> Hold on, Muhammad. I'm only quoting.
This is what
doesn't mean all the creatures. So why
you requesting this truth now? Is Allah
not the Lord of all the worlds?
>> You just misqued this. You mistransated
the scripture.
>> You don't know Arabic? Don't talk about
it.
>> The Lord of all the worlds.
>> Go to the other scholars, man.
>> Is he the
Lord of all the worlds, Muhammad?
>> Whatever, Avery. Whatever.
>> What do you mean? Whatever. I just Is he
or not?
>> It's been It's been nice talking to you,
man. You just
>> I'm just saying.
>> Thank you [clears throat]
for having me.
>> I wish you a peace peaceful day.
>> Take care, man. I appreciate it. Don't
be stoning no monkeys, bro.
>> Yeah, don't stone no monkeys. Ladies and
gentlemen, Allah is the Lord of all the
worlds. And don't forget, whenever he
sends a messenger,
he sends a messenger to a nation in
their language. So there was some
messenger either it was a monkey itself
or a messenger who knew the languages of
the monkeys who was able to convey the
laws of a law to them. So when she
disobeyed, she got stoned for it. Yeah.
>> How do we know that the monkey the
monkeys didn't have their own prophet
that went up on the mountain and brought
down the tablet for them logic? How do
we not know?
>> Well, this is this is in the pre-Islamic
uh period of of ignorance. So, we're
ignorant of that.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> There it is.
>> We're ignorant of that.
>> I mean, they don't seem too ignorant.
They know the the penalty for adultery.
[laughter]
How did they do that? if they're
ignorant, where did these moral codes
and standards come from?
>> That's a good question. And so what like
is this a religion that's different from
Islam? Like is is this a there was a
religion before Islam that Allah like
like you know instituted where adultery
was not allowed and you know there was a
punishment the punishment is stoning
like that's that's this this gets you
thinking. This gets you thinking.
>> Yeah. The monkey too. Apparently, Islam
didn't exist before the birth of this
man here, Amomar bin Mum. Wow.
Interesting.
>> Do you know that?
>> But hold on. But isn't But don't all of
the animals prostrate to Allah?
>> They sure do. They always in Islam, they
practicing, hey, what they always tell
us, Jesus was a Muslim cuz he
prostrated. All of the animals are
Muslim cuz they prostrate to Allah. So,
Subhan Allah. Subhan Allah.
>> They weren't too ignorant. They was
prostrating and they was getting some
revelation from somebody. Maybe it was
Caesar from Planet of the Apes brought
it. Somebody did it.
>> That's who that's who it was. It was
Caesar.
>> It was Caesar.
>> Caesar. He's